well brian educators are now
eligible for the covenant vaccine but
are unable to register right now however
some are still finding a way
eight news now reporter kristen drummond
spoke with some teachers about their
efforts
a concern with the vaccine rollout for
educators
what we've seen so far has been
frustrating and it seems super
disorganized
vicki kreidel questions the logistics
while she managed to get an appointment
the second grade teacher at hurt
elementary school says scheduling
remains an issue
we work full time and
you know to to go in during the day is a
problem like
a lot of us could maybe do it but we
have to take a half day off work
so we have to put in for a sub ahead of
time other teachers complain about the
inability to even register
just the website is down and it just
says come back later and you know we all
have lives to live
and we're not just going to sit around
waiting for a computer screen to load
constantly
the clark county school district does
not require educators to get the covid19
vaccine
but some want it before returning to the
classroom
a few even managed getting a vaccination
recently
sometime last week we were told that
there was a drop down that included
educators like it's on
it somebody started telling us and so
there was a few people that were able to
get in
i got several text messages from many
teachers that
you know i got my appointment and one
that i know has already been vaccinated
tam larner is principal at spring valley
high school he says
most teachers on his campus seem to want
the vaccine
a choice when considering being back in
classrooms with students
they know that the vaccine is an
important step through making that
happen
motivation for some to keep trying to
register
kristin drummond 8 news now
now the clark county education
association is surveying ccsd educators
about the vaccine
the teachers union says out of more than
13 000 people so far
they say a majority do support getting a
vaccination